[Música]
vamos con nuestro segundo espacio
económico y ya nos vuelve a acompañar en
el estudio Juan Pablo de lucumí Hola de
nuevo acá estamos otra vez y Juan Pablo
precisamente Nos traes algo una noticia
de última hora podríamos decir y son las
proyecciones del Banco Mundial no que
acaban de salir las proyecciones
mundiales del fmi perdón Así es son
proyecciones del fmi que pues hay datos
de acerca de la zona Euro de América
Latina sus proyecciones y en general lo
que hizo fue recortar las previsiones de
crecimiento mundial al 2,8% para el 2023
desde el 2,9% es una Pues un recorte
bastante pequeño pero si se pues se
compara por ejemplo con el crecimiento
de 2022 cuando fue el 3,4% pues se tiene
en cuenta de que es considerable también
por ejemplo recortó el crecimiento para
América Latina hasta el 1,6% para el
2023 y que será el mismo crecimiento
pues se prevé que sea el mismo
crecimiento para Estados Unidos también
el 1,6% pero para este país digamos que
es una proyección positiva el FM y
también dijo que la economía mundial
sigue delicada y podría presentarse un
escenario de efecto dominó debido a la
quiebra de los bancos regionales
estadounidenses y la adquisición forzosa
de crédito Swift por parte de su
competidor de vs Y cómo avanzamos a Juan
Pablo la situación de tensión no tanto
política como ya hasta ahora militar
alrededor de Taiwán también afecta a la
economía de La Isla Así es por séptimo
mes consecutivo se contrajeron las
exportaciones de Taiwán en marzo las
exportaciones cayeron un
19,1% en valor con respecto al año
anterior según dijo el ministro de
finanzas de La Isla los datos quedaron
por detrás de las previsiones de una
encuesta que realizó pronosticaba una
contracción del 15,4% para dar un
ejemplo la empresa taiwanesa que es El
fabricante por chips de contrato más
grande del mundo y uno de los
proveedores más antes de Apple y otros
gigantes tecnológicos informó el lunes
que sus ventas de marzo habían caído un
15,4% respecto al año anterior las
autoridades financieras no están
sorprendidas con el dato y esperan que
la tendencia continúe hasta el cuarto
trimestre de este año un escenario que
ellos suponen pues que se da por la
demanda mundial que todavía mantiene
débil y incluidos los pedidos de China
el mayor mercado de exportaciones de la
isla y volvamos ahora a América Latina
hablemos de Colombia y México pero
empecemos por Colombia así es la
colombiana de reparto rappi dijo el
lunes que comprará la empresa brasileña
Box Delivery que ofrece un servicio
similar aunque rappi ya opera en Brasil
y es una de las principales empresas de
domicilios en ese país la compra de box
deliver será complementario para la
compañía colombiana porque Box está
centrada en contactar a los entregadores
y a los comercios pero no cuenta con una
aplicación destinada al consumidor final
Box Delivery creada en 2016 realiza más
de un millón de al mes cuenta con cerca
de 200.000 repartidores en Brasil y
tiene entre sus clientes a cadenas de
comida rápida como Burger King Pizza Hut
y McDonald's y Juan Pablo hablemos ahora
de México porque ya se oficializó la
quiebra de la aerolínea Interjet Así es
es oficial El juez Saúl Martínez quien
es el titular del juzgado segundo del
distrito de materia de concursos
mercantiles esto en Ciudad de México
declaró el lunes la quiebra legítima de
la aerolínea Interjet luego de dos años
de que la compañía hubiera detenido sus
operaciones en el comunicado se le abro
comillas se ordena al sindicato que
proceda a la venta de los bienes y
derechos que integran la masa procurando
obtener el mayor producto posible por su
enajenación y a fin de hacer pago a los
acreedores cierro comillas la aerolínea
mexicana bajo la razón ABC aerolíneas
inició el proceso de concurso mercantil
desde agosto de 2022 tras parar sus
operaciones en diciembre del 2020 un mes
antes en noviembre los trabajadores de
la empresa Iniciar una huelga por deudas
de la compañía que superan los 263
millones de dólares Todo el proceso de
quiebra Interjet llegó pese a las
esperanzas de sus exdirectores Pues de
rescatar la aerolínea Qué está pasando
con las aerolíneas lo revisaremos ya lo
decíamos les decíamos sí lo esperamos
Juan Pablo y Cerramos porque con china
no porque usted quiere fijarse en la
inflación de ese país Por qué Así es
pues es el dato inflacionario más bajo
desde septiembre 2021 y pues cuando
alcanzó el país en marzo el índice de
precios al consumidor fue del 0,7%
interanual el ipc cayó un 0,3% respecto
al dato de febrero cuando fue del 1%
este mes pues lo que habría impulsado el
dato optimista para el país sería la
caída de los precios de los alimentos
según datos oficiales presentados Este
martes y qué hay de los indicadores
diarios pues Seguimos entonces en Asia
porque las bolsas de esas regiones
estuvieron motivadas por el dato de
inflación que acabamos de dar y por el
anuncio del nuevo gobernador del banco
de Japón Cuando dio pistas acerca de
cómo será la política monetaria de ese
país las bolsas europe as Siguen
operando con tendencia al alza los
principales indicadores de Frankfurt
Londres y París reportaron ganancias
Juan Pablo Muchas gracias entonces por
todo este repaso económico nos vemos
mañana nosotros vamos en directo a París